our buddy former navy chaplain gordon
clinging schmidt resurfaced we didn't
cover the story originally but our
friend kyle kolinsky over at secular
talk did let's take a look at the clip
so every now and then a public school in
Kentucky or Missouri or some other red
state will put up the Ten Commandments
and the freedom from religion foundation
or the ACLU will have to sue them so
they take it down now constitutionally
this this isn't an open question or a
secular nation we're not a theocracy so
they have to take it down um but a
right-wing hostname Gordon
Klingenschmitt doesn't like this and he
has some thoughts on it let's listen we
know from the Bible that God gave Moses
the Ten Commandments including thou
shalt not kill and other things now
these are good ideas that we ought to
teach children that's kind of the
purpose of Education in some ways is to
teach them morality and yet here is this
little girl and God bless her maybe
she's put up to it by her atheist mother
or the Atheist lawyers or whatever but
this little girl has a violent reaction
to something in the Ten Commandments
what is that thing inside of her or more
specifically inside of her mother and
certainly inside of the Freedom From
Religion Foundation lawyers what is that
thing inside of them that hates the word
of god so much that it causes them to
have psychological injury and trauma
that's not the school district it's the
demonic spirit inside of them that is
what needs deliverance and healing and
honestly they should have more exposure
to the Ten Commandments so that they
would be free from their demonic
influence so if you're against the Ten
Commandments at school or at a court
because demon your demonically possessed
did you know it sounds like some [ __ ]
that somebody would say in Saudi Arabia
like if somebody tepidly spoke up and
said hey you know maybe we should
separate mosque and state and maybe the
Quran shouldn't be as heavily involved
in public life as it is
what would they say they say Oh Satan
has gotten you and Allah must save us
all so let's [ __ ] you know expel you
from the country and let's say you're
demonically possessed in all this [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] these are crazy people man
this is a crazy person who how can you
read how can anybody really believe that
hey I disagree that maybe maybe we
shouldn't have a theocracy that's my
opinion all the demons must get you so
isn't that [ __ ] convenient it so
whenever you disagree with the Christian
fundamentalists like Gordon
Klingenschmitt it's never because hey
you thought it out and you have a
difference of opinion and here here your
detailed reasons your nuanced
explanation it's a dream and you're
dreaming what a sad life that is anybody
who's ever disagreed with me on issues
involving government or religion well
you're just demonically possessed now
furthermore the Ten Commandments like
people act like or these guys act like
off they're so important there are
everything that's all we need have you
ever read through them i am the lord thy
god no other gods before me no graven
images or likenesses don't take the
Lord's name in vain remember the Sabbath
day honor thy mother and father that's
where six deep so far not a single one
of these is a law nor should they be
thou shalt not kill we finally got one
law and one that makes sense now shot
thou shalt not commit adultery bear
false witness against thy neighbor covet
thy neighbor's wife most of them the
majority of the Ten Commandments are
just silly i am the lord thy god no
other gods before me no graven images
don't take the Lord's name in vain [ __ ]
that so there this is so funny because
what Kyle didn't mention here and may
not even know understandably is that
this is not even close to Gordon's
craziest belief we've we've interviewed
Gordon Klingenschmitt a number of times
I don't know at this point if it's six
seven or eight over the years but one
what I see is one of his most outrageous
beliefs is
that he believes that number one
exorcism is a thing he believes that gay
exorcism is a thing he believes himself
to be an expert in gay exorcism and he
believes that he has done I don't know
how many many many gay exorcisms which
have quote cured or removed the
homosexuality from the I called the
victim of the exorcism he would probably
call them a beneficiary so there's and
and that's just the tip of the iceberg
this guy has told me before that demons
can attach themselves to animals
including pigs and all sorts of other
crazy stuff so the question to you is
should we get Gordon Klingenschmitt back
on the show now of course I'm assuming
he would accept in the past he has never
turned down the opportunity to appear
it's possible that he wouldn't anymore
but my question to you is would you be
interested in getting an update from
Gordon Klingenschmitt particularly he
became a Colorado State Representative
and then his out and I don't know if he
opted not to run for re-election or was
defeated I haven't been following the
world of Gordon for a while now but
there may be an interesting conversation
there ok so let me know in the comments
do you want Gordon back on the show and
make sure to click on the link in the
description to check out kyle's full
video in its Channel